[Music]
one American airplane Factory one of
many one bomber thousands on the
way an angel of
death death to those who marcket free
people death to those who tell the world
they are out to wreck the American
democratic
system hundreds here
thousands tens of thousands on the
way
test flight every part tested every
piece of metal tested every bolt rivet
and welded seam tested under the
pressure of combat
conditions off the ground now for the
first time as a complete fighting
unit
power power to travel far dump her bombs
and return power to say I can outfly and
out fight any Pursuit ship now fighting
over Europe I am the strength of the
people of the Free
[Music]
World
w
here you get our
insides aluminum alloy light and strong
steel Copper Brass a dozen other metals
put together like a fine
watch Wings made strong to hold her high
in the air while she
delivers each Wing built to take all the
pounding a superpowered motor can give
it
and here is the fire B where the bomber
begins to
grow born in fire to Fight
Fire with
[Music]
Fire she's going to have the guts win
stamina fight and deliver death a belly
full of it to those who are asking for
it made of metals tempered and strong
woven together
strong American mass production American
knoow hands with knoow Minds with
American
knowhow
these workers these riveters welders
Drillers all these Craftsmen have pride
a genuine pride in their share their
participation in the Titanic job we call
National Defense
production PA more than 25,000 for each
ship parts stacked up was seem to be
assembled and woven into a living
Destroyer traveling the
sky we are taking these parts weaving
them into a thing that breathes and
lives breathes with a spirit of America
the spirit that
says Don't Tread On
Me
made to stand heavy toil in
struggle made to stand sharp and storm
and heavy travel ready to flank and
outflank the enemy packing enough power
to climb over the highest anti-aircraft
barrage
everything under
control from hundreds of sub assemblies
from scores of Major
assemblies these precision-built
sections roll into final
[Music]
assembly day and night night 24 hours a
day 7 days a week
365 days a year body bones and wings
roll and join into the form of a
finished breathing
bomber
bombers thousands in the air now tens of
thousands on the
way the motor raw naked Power a Niagara
of
horsepower John Henry on One Wing Paul
bunan on the
[Music]
other wires miles of wires link the
nerve centers of the
ship the giant Wings Spar protects the
cables from enemy
gunfire
and she packs guns so many guns the Army
won't let us tell about a flying Arena
she's the toughest fighting the ship of
our size in the
air here is America
strarted key aware
alive
massive
honest this Wing seems to say You Can
Count On
[Music]
Me Da
daylight over Europe over Asia
night black
[Music]
night
America flies into the dawn bombers for
a new
[Music]
day
Humanity with all its fears
with all its hopes of future
years is hanging
breathless on thy
feet